I'm Francesca and I might have 99
problems but Ramadan ain't one that's
not the case though for Muslims on
Twitter who started a trending hashtag
Ramadan problems
that's right Muslims around the world
are in the middle of observing the
holiest month in the Islamic calendar
Ramadan they can't eat drink or engage
in sexual activity from sunup to sundown
it's supposed to be a time of spiritual
growth and patience but it's summer hint
really long days and many are coming up
short on both luckily there's social
media to take Muslims minds off their
stomachs the real mr. Khan tweeted these
fasts aren't very fast are they Yara
Khaleesi tweeted a picture of a litter
of adorable puppies with the line is it
bad I thought they were fried chicken
yes yes it is
then there's Haram police who tweeted
staring at the fridge like it's your ex
you want to but you know you shouldn't
in response to the very predictable
questions Muslims get during Ramadan
Shia al Tamimi tweeted this photo no not
even water you see and for the moment of
the day when Muslims can finally break
their fast a son of men tweeted this
vine of a sloth gorging itself on
carrots tell me you don't break your
fast with carrots but Ramadan is also
about being on your best behavior
cops tweeted been bloody starving myself
all day only to find out crude comments
break your fast to put wada brow films
posted this meme 11 months of Playboy
one month of pray boy oh snap
for the non-muslims Amani bodhrán
tweeted out this Ramadan ecard by Sami
cards since you can't engage in gossip
lust or obscenity during Ramadan let's
just reconnect in August so see you or
someone you know have Ramadan problems
tweet us at aj+
and thanks for watching